who do you think was number two
on the list of highest paid youtubers
this year number two does anybody uh
have a name that comes to mind no i was
gonna say lele pons but she's lele ponce
yeah she's a good girl that you'd know
but shout out to lele how about you i
wasn't like ryan but you just looked at
me he was he was top ten how about let's
pull this up drum roll please
jake paul
earned 45 million dollars
this year in 2021 boxing 40 million from
boxing and five million outside of the
rankings so he's doing like youtube
videos though he did he made five
million dollars
doing videos okay
you're laughing okay he made 40 million
dollars all those fights where he kicks
the [ __ ] out of like has been ufc guys
yeah ben askren tyron woodley twice
uh
40 million freaking dollars everyone in
their mother has been rooting against
this guy yeah since he started fighting
100 and you know what it's a great
narrative he's got the last laugh
the problem child 45 million dollars by
the way i think he bought a couple
ridiculous apartments him and his
brother at the new 11 residences
downtown yeah so maybe we end up
partying
there's 11 residences yeah like 11 the
club yeah now they got residences
exactly they're just shortening
downstairs to upstairs here's what
they're all in one just stay there
between mr beast making this money
between jake paul kicking the [ __ ] out
of ufc's guys between youtubers making
all this money between crypto it's
almost like any left it's it's almost
like
any like any like this guy oh my no way
turned on its head right like anything
that just seems so far-fetched
unbelievable this is happening is
happening covey the whole world shut
down know what yep
well it started with five trillion
dollars stimulus boom started with who
our president which one the last one 26
yeah i agree okay donald trump become
president yeah it was like no [ __ ]
way and then it happened yeah even joe
biden what the hell how'd that happen
anyway this isn't a political show okay
um
so real quick stats and then i want to
get your thoughts on uh our friend jake
paul over here i be i believe you're
fighting him next i hope yeah oh well i
mean i've dm don't forget
yeah he's gonna knock that mustache off
your face i don't know he's gonna close
up on that stash it'll be gone pretty
soon he's gonna knock that thing off by
the way the 45 million dollars that he
made would make him number 20 of the
world's highest paid athletes he'd be
number 20. no okay in a year what yes 40
he would be the number one highest-paid
boxer in the entire world well we're
sponsoring nowadays well thank you
exactly canelo is number two canelo uh
viva mexico yeah
mexico i apologize i apologize for my
latina living limitlessly uh and my
white girl living
with a lot of restrictions
canelo um was the 48th highest-paid
athlete so jake paul killing the
freaking game so let me ask you jake
paul you're blonde he's blonde blonde
thank you i'm like let's have aryan
babies
what are your thoughts on jake paul
um
as a i don't know him as he is as a
person is he a piece of [ __ ] is he hot
is he not what is paul or his
personality yeah i'm not asking
literally this the picture on the screen
is his face bloody yeah 45 million
dollars to clean that up real quick so
you don't have any you don't have any
strong feelings about jake paul
no nothing
jenny what are your thoughts on this guy
he had no idea who he was what do you
mean no yeah no okay listen i had no
this is what i mean that this is genius
like they know what they're doing they
have a team of people like their pr team
is killing the game their marketing team
killing the game yeah i had no idea who
this guy is girl by the way if you go
back to the last picture i think her
name is julie ooh amber you gotta come
through strong girl
[Laughter]
um i had no idea who he was and then i
see that floyd mayweather is fighting
is that i bought the fight thinking it
was an actual fight i wanted to see
floyd no and when i see this i'm like so
confused i realized it was this whole
influencer thing that was happening and
i said wow so the only reason i know
them is because of the fight okay of
course you don't feel lighter than his
brother although i think so yeah
although i have mad respect for sports
and i'm not like
i still think sports like athletes need
to be in a category of their own i think
that this is a great um
marketing tool for them to be able to
come so one day you just decide you want
to be a boxer and because of your
influence you're like okay but that just
goes
where our generation is going like
they're gonna you have to be sponsorship
and it's all about sponsorships right
sponsorships will pay somebody that's
gonna get more views than somebody who's
more athletic and doesn't have as much
depending on the brand because some
people want authenticity but it's like a
college degree it's more important than
a college student show a picture of the
brothers together anyway keep going
what's more important than a college
grade
followers like instead of going to
college for four years i should have
just been making videos in my room so
that i can go boxing shirts off go
now
to try
wait but i'm confused why who's hotter
okay
left or right don't even say names left
or right i mean i like left's body yeah
i like left spotty but i feel like i
can't see their face so yeah david can
we get a damn close-up on the face
coming up so because the face is really
the most important for me actually okay
um but anyway i was saying that
influence is more important than a
bachelor's degree
so make your point please
i'm just saying that influence is more
important than a bachelor or a like a
bachelor of arts what the [ __ ] did i
need that for yes like i'm not getting
booked for commercials because the girl
next to me has 100k followers and the
people who book want free marketing
amber you bring up an amazing point
thank you very much okay
[Music]